Don Lemon says he was fired by CNN lemon
said he's stunned and learned the news
from his agent quote Don will forever be
a part of the CNN family we thank him
for his contributions over the past 17
years we wish him well and will be
cheering him on in his future endeavors
well I'll be cheering on his departure
so we're all cheering for something how
about that CNN
after 17 years at CNN I would have
thought that someone in management would
have had the decency to tell me directly
at no time was I ever given any
indication that I would not be able to
continue to do the work that I have
loved at the network it is clear that
there are some larger issues at play now
I got to agree first James O'Keefe then
Don Lemon people are going after very
prom okay so what we are concerned about
James o'keevan Carlson we're actually
happy with the Don Lemon thing so uh it
is strange though in a lot of shake-up
in media so he thinks no one at CNN
actually told him apparently he's lying
okay I guess well that's why he worked
there yeah can I just say that my
favorite part about his firing is that
he couldn't even accurately report on
his own firing come on John damn I mean
it's also interesting to me that we're
all like oh so Tucker's probably gonna
go independent whereas like we're like
what is he gonna do
what happened to Brian stelter that's
where Don lemon's going we just know he
is not going independent and partially
this like how could they do this to me
statement proves how much he wants to
stay with the machine it's just such a
clear uh contrast in the mentalities
right we have no hope for him did you
guys see Brian stelter on that uh he did
that interview who was that interview
with
I think it was news news Nation or
something and he's like why were you
fired Brian and he's like I don't know I
really have no idea and everyone's like
really Brian you know you don't know
your boss explained exactly why he was
firing people and it's like your boss
comes out and says I'm going to fire
partisan actors who are activists and
not journalists Brian Stalter you're
fired me I wonder why that happened
yeah how could you do this to me says
Brian no that's Don Lemon is like I
can't believe this happened are you
kidding dude also you made Caitlyn
Collins cry it's been reported yeah I
mean part of it is this idea like how
could Senior Management not contact me
like maybe it's because they don't want
to talk to you because you're difficult
to deal with like that's why they made
their own agent tell you because they
didn't want to have a scene in the
building they didn't want to deal with a
call like it yeah sometimes a person is
like a maniac that's a fair point and
Don Lemon fits that that you know
profile
what are you talking about Tim you you
answer you you answer you hired canceled
people you should uh dude get your get
your other chair Jeremy boring posted
something like many people are asking
about daily wire making an offer Tucker
but wherever Tucker lands he'll be
successful and then he later posted many
people are asking about the daily wire
hiring Don Lemon I'm just kidding
nobody's asking that well that would be
an amazing though John Lemon goes to the
Daily wire right it's a sad State of
Affairs because basically everyone on
cable news is somebody who would never
have gotten a platform if they had to
build it up on their own you know let me
let me tell you that's an important
Point yeah and how much how much was Don
Lemon getting paid too much
been with a network for 17 years four
million well uh let's see is is a salary
is estimated to be four million dollars
per year
I'm thinking about that right nobody
likes Don Lemon like even the left
doesn't like Don Lemon nobody nobody
likes him oh now I'm starting to feel
bad for him you're really going in on
this but it's okay he can just move to
San Francisco and get reparations we'll
be fine here's what I'm thinking about
what's we're talking about what could
this guy do now that he's like lost his
job he can't get a job at a movie
theater as a manager right because
they'd be like dude you're Don Lemon
like we're gonna it's gonna cause issues
you're overqualified
get out no it is yeah yeah like high
profile individuals can't get regular
jobs for the most part because they're
just like you're a huge liability we
don't want the attention we don't want
the commotion and we don't believe that
you'd actually take the job and stick
with it so Don Lemon where could he
possibly go
I'm imagining what it would be like to
be Don Lemon and to be hanging out
semi-retired because you got fired at a
bar do you think people are gonna go to
Don Lemon and be like hey man I'm a big
fan sorry to hear what happened
no way so it depends on the kind of bar
I guess no I don't think I don't think
based on the way the left and the right
view down limit that there's any
circumstance where he shows up somewhere
and they're like wow Don Lemon I'm just
a big fan of your work they might be
like oh yeah you're Don Lemon how about
that you never go to the center left bar
down the
streets I know he's like he's like he's
like weirdo Pandoras to corporate test
yeah and people are gonna be like ah
look it's Don Lemon get a job dude
that's what they're gonna do he's gonna
become a twitch streamer he's gonna be
biggest one I I think that would be an
amazing character Arc but also I think
he's gonna do what a lot of people who
kind of failed their way out of the uh
career they're in whether it be meteor
politics and he's gonna go to be going
to Academia he's just gonna become a
professor some college is going to be
like oh God lemon we will just give you
tenure right away and you can teach the
next generation of people and then we
get to tell like bring you out whenever
we're like look how fast he checks all
the Dei boxes as well so that's a good
point this is the reason why as well
media is so dead because the next
generation of Journalism students are
being taught and indoctrinated by people
like Don Lemon and Brian stelter it's
truly incredible yeah it's not a great
system but it's the one that exists
that's where Liz Cheney is Cheney's
teaching at what University of Virginia
anybody actually watch Don Lemon but but
he's a name people know so I I hear I I
think I agree with Hannah Claire that
some University will be like
bro we only hire people who don't know
anything what if CNN offered you four
million dollars a year to host the
morning show with Caitlin Collins uh I
would say that's far too much it's gonna
be a giant waste of money I'm gonna go
do it and then I would go in there and
on the first day I would say everything
that they no I mean I'd say with the yes
CNN reach out to me let's have a
conversation you can contact my people
but I mean it's a serious question yeah
what are you are you really like what
would I have CNN have a show with me I
would explain I would like explain to
the the public why the sexual Revolution
is a farce in this country's right
Christian values and that would be my
morning show I'd be like this coffee is
terrible but you know what's even worse
John's been done to mankind John money
Alfred Kinsey I would turn the first
Morning Show into a presentation on
Alfred Kinsey no but in all seriousness
if if CNN tried poaching a
anti-establishment or right-leaning
personality and the CEO is like look we
don't want to be partisan
should they do it right like would you
take a morning anchor position at CNN
absolutely not you liar no but I don't
know I'm not a money person and I uh CNN
is a laughing stock I'd be embarrassed
to work there to be quite honest with
you see I feel like shame is kind of
right to be like yes I'll take the money
and then I'll just continue to be myself
and they can fire me like if you have an
ironclad contract where it's like if you
want to fire me you have to pay me an
additional million dollars like no just
run it out for six weeks ready to go
there is because again I really do truly
feel like corporate media is dead so
going to CNN would just kill my career
just be pointless yeah you're picking me
off the carcass but you're still making
four million dollars all right I see
what you're saying that's what I'm
saying like you go into CNN you look at
the camera and you explain all of the
horrible things that the industrial
military complex is doing and the wars
they're pushing us into you explain to
them yeah and the fed you explain to
them the the farce of sexual Liberation
you explain to them what's happening to
these children and then mutilated by
doctors and then you lead a a segment
with a few moments of prayer silent
prayer exactly and then they're like all
right now away if you want to reach the
people most in need actually going to
CNN is essentially a missionary trip
oh yeah you Tim you just asked me if I
would go to Nineveh for four million
dollars or whether I would go into the
belly of that whale I'm choosing the
whale you're better than me you're
better well Jonah did it first too and
yeah so uh the other thing is I've
actually gotten a bunch of messages from
people and they were like your main
competition for 8 pm has been removed
and it's like I look for us stuck across
almost competition for Tucker Carlson we
are not competition you know what I mean
like the twitch has been past Tim this
is a lot of pressure on you I don't know
like announce you are the news
on the show and then he says uh you just
watch Tim cast iron off no one yeah you
should ask Tucker to be your new co-host
dude but I think the the reason I was
asking about CNN is because Chris Licht
is clearly trying to fix the network I'm
not sure if it can be done because like
if uh if you bought a car and then like
some guy say it's Don Lemon when inside
that car and then defecated all over the
seats the nice leather seats that
happened to a friend of mine actually
and then left the car in the Sun for you
know several days to fester in the
summer heat in Las Vegas
and and then I knew the car was given
was bought by some guys like I'm gonna
clean this up you know I still wouldn't
want to ride in the car yeah you know
what I mean there's nothing you could
you could replace the inside and
everything I'm just like you don't want
to be in a car that Don Lemon sat in but
it's not that whole value people are
gonna see you driving around in it and
they're gonna be like dude you're
driving around in that car full of crap
it's like we cleaned it man it's like
well I hope so he who humbles himself
what did you say who humbles himself
will be exalted if that's what CNN is I
would go there and I would spread the
truth and I would I would I would take
the embarrassment of being on CNN but
there's an important point to this
conversation which is that as we're
talking about CNN every single one of us
like that would be super embarrassing to
be honest I would be like absolutely
can I can I play for you the clip that
got Don Lemon fired so this is from
Aaron rupar the notorious uh was he
still with Vox I don't know where he
works uh I guess not he's according to
the New York Times interview that Don
Lemon conducted last week with the vague
ramaswami played a role in his firing
note co-host Poppy Harlow silently while
lemon goes after Vivek check this out
is it gonna play fine I find your
explanation reductive and actually
insulting including to Black Americans
to say that black people today compared
to 1964 1865 haven't made progress in
part because of the freedoms we secured
and the Second Amendment please I cannot
keep a thought if you guys are talking
to me in my ear so hang on one second so
to say that yeah wait wait I got to
pause you hear that Don Lemon is talking
to the producers telling them to stop
talking to my ear they're probably
saying Don shut up up stop and he goes I
can't I can't do this and then he goes
off it's not the first time he's done
this black people secured their freedoms
after the Civil War is a historical fact
Don just study it only after their
second amendment rights were secured
that's not secured their freedoms after
the Civil War that is not your you are
discounting uh reconstruction you're
discounting a whole host of things that
happen after the Civil War when it comes
to African Americans including the whole
reason that the Civil Rights Movement
happened is because black people did not
secure their freedoms after the Civil
War and that things turned around people
were tried to change the freedoms that
we're supposed to you know how they got
it they got their second amendment
rights and they actually got the NRA
played a big role in that but today down
NRA did not play a game
that's a lie that's not they already did
not play a big role this is just
historical facts the part that I find
because you say it's historical part
that I find insulting is when you say
today black Americans don't have those
rights after we have gone through that
civil rights revolution in this country
you are sitting here telling an
African-American about the rights and
what you find insulting about the the
way I live the skin I live in every day
here's where you and I have a great
point of black and white that black
people don't have in this country and
that black people do have well here's
where you and I have a different point
of view I think we should be able to
express our views regardless of the
color of our skin we should have this
debate without me regarding you as a
black man insulting that you're
regarding you as a fellow citizen you're
sitting here whatever ethnicity you are
explaining to me whatever explaining
whatever
I think we should have this debate black
white doesn't matter I think we should
have the same content of the idea do it
you should do it in an honest way and in
a better way and what you're doing is
not an honest and Fair Way okay we
appreciate you coming on could you
imagine buying a car that's been just
like stained with Don lemon's crap I got
it and then you're like trying to
convince people you're making it better
but Don Lemon keeps crapping in the
front seat I gotta be honest I am so
sick of whatever ethnicity you are
privilege it is whatever ethnicity you
are wow no I just want to be popular
right now he went for being racist
without knowing what without even
knowing he's like he's like I don't know
what stereotype to insult you with like
I'm just gonna assume there is something
so uh but I think the the real the real
reason I got fighters right there in the
beginning I'm gonna play that again so
with due respect I find I find your
explanation reductive and actually
insulting including to Black Americans
to say that black people today compared
to 1964 1865 haven't made progress in
part because of the freedoms we secured
and the Second Amendment please I cannot
keep a thought if you guys are talking
to me in my ear so right there I cannot
to me in my ear CNN is so horribly
mismanaged I bet they were saying stop
arguing be a journalist stop arguing ask
him his views and move on and Don was
like no black lives matter if he asks
some questions he might know what
ethnicity he is that's right no no no
it's not about uh who's interviewing
it's about Don Lemon right he's here to
make these points whatever ethnicity you
are and move on I think that's what's
hard he is used to interviewing guests
who are maybe a little sycophantic he's
not prepared to not that Vivek is being
hostile they're just obviously a
different side so he's not prepared to
go go into an interview with someone who
he disagrees with he wants people to
support his beliefs only and I think
that summarizes a lot of the hosts on
CNN and their viewership right it is
ultimately to reinforce your own world
be aware as like contrasting Tucker
Tucker was like look we got to talk
about this stuff that's happening even
if you don't like it or even if you're
skeptical about it Jeff Zucker
slithered into CNN
and then defecate into the brains of
their hosts because Don Lemon if you
watch his videos from like 10 years ago
was a very very different I was going to
bring that up if you just played a clip
of old Don Lemon versus new Don Lemon
completely different people completely
different like yeah Don Lemon I wouldn't
say mirrored Tucker but he he made good
points he was a normal human being he
actually seemed like he cared about
reporting and you know highlighting
issues that were actually affecting
people whereas now it's all propaganda
so uh this clip is just incredible we
love to say it we love to see people
imploding you know via their own actions
I just wish we could get the audio like
I wish to leak the audio of whatever
they were saying to Don Lemon like
please just move on don't say anything
don't don't do anything no it's a
producer being like Don please you need
to stop and then he goes I can't keep a
thought if you're talking about my ear
he goes I'm sorry or it was the
producers trying to like feed him
talking points to counter the vague yeah
you know what this is occurring to me
too so his network is most likely
getting mad at him for for being
annoying but it's not like he broke a
particular story that anyone is
speculating that they're mad at him for
I think that really says something
because with Tucker Carlson we are
speculating well maybe it was the
January 6th story maybe it was about the
Dominion voting systems whatever it
might be he stepped on a lot of toes
which theoretically is what a journalist
is supposed to do what story has Don
Lemon broke of any consequence that any
person in power oh would be upset about
oh uh he broke the story that he is a
black man who has personal experiences
that I think is wrong about see well I
didn't know that so thank you for
informing me now I have so much more
respect for his uh journalistic
abilities now that's right his lived
experience I mean couldn't figure out
whatever ethnicity that guy was his
lived experience yeah but he knew about
his own lived experience isn't that so
dismissive though to hold your own uh
ethnic or racial identity
as so important to you and then just
totally dismiss somebody else like
whatever you are I mean but that's the
entire modern day yeah it's either your
race your sexuality whatever makes you
the most special and then you just use
that to Discount anybody who disagrees
with your claims that's it so easy for
sure but if you're going to be race
obsessed at least be obsessed with my
actual race remember that whatever you
are saying I'm not from whatever you are
there was a phone call interview and
there was a black radio host and it was
like a white woman and she was like well
you wouldn't understand because you're
white and he goes what ma'am I'm black
and she's like what he's like I'm black
and she's like you are like her whole
world view is just totally racist and
she couldn't understand that there are
like black people who have opinions and
then the weirdest thing these white
liberals who are like they they they
can't fathom someone like Candace Owens
or Larry Elder or Thomas Sowell those
people must be white supremacists or
something or not exist at all yeah
people tell me that I want to be white
so bad because I uh use my brain and
I've done research Regarding why our
country is where it is so uh that means
I'm trying to be a white person
apparently yeah I remember uh I told the
story before about when I was at the
Dakota access pipeline protest and I had
a white dude tell me that uh
Asian when he mentioned that being on
time for meetings was colonial thinking
no no that's what he told me and then I
was like what are you talking about it's
like I have a meeting I gotta leave and
he's like that's what the colonists
Native Americans they didn't do that
they just you know they knew when to
wake up and then I was like what are you
talking about Asians have us have have
schedules too like what what and he was
like yeah but let's be real like white
people brought that stuff to Asia and I
was like Asians invented the compass
1000 years before you did dude I'm not
gonna sit here and listen to a white
supremacist tell me he invented all
culture in the world but these people
genuinely believe it they like they're
white people who think they did
everything and anything good and like
stoic or work related or responsible is
they think it's just them and they must
bring it to all the lowly others exactly
well it's not just that right because
then they hate those things they hate
those good things and they also blame
white people for them at the same time
while taking credit for them so yeah
something like having schedules and
being on time that's why people think
like the ancient Egyptians had sundials
other cultures have had a concept of
linear time because it turns out like
people figured out pretty early on that
like one thing happens after another
thing and that you can figure out what
you're going to do based on what things
in nature do in their Cycles like where
the sun is at in the sky for example and
when we gotta harvest the grass to make
our beer thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time